mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre manger
des pommes c'est fini nous l'avons bien
compris aujourd'hui nos vergers de
pommiers sont en danger nos pomiculteurs
sont à l'agonie hausse des coups de
production principalement dû à la crise
énergétique baisse le rendement et un
prix d'achat par les grossistes et les
grandes surfaces sans cesse revues à la
baisse nous assistons là à un véritable
massacre à la tronçonneuse sont pas mémo
sont ceux que j'entends sans arrêt sur
le terrain un chiffre pour illustrer
l'impact économique pour cette filière
le coût du stockage moyen connaît une
hausse de plus de
400%. nos arboriculteurs ont dû aussi
faire face en 2022 à tant d'aller à
climatiques gel épisode de grêle
sécheresse historique ils sont
aujourd'hui acculés par la crise
énergétique un autre chiffre si vous le
permettez aujourd'hui la grande
distribution achète à moins de 30
centimes le kilo de pommes alors que le
coût de production est à 45 centimes
mais qu'en toute logique il faut des
vendre nos pommes à 50 centimes le bon
prix ce n'est pas le bas prix le bon
prix c'est le juste prix celui qui va
permettre à nos moteur de pomme de vivre
tout simplement dignement de leur métier
alors Monsieur le Ministre venait
d'annoncer votre plan de souveraineté
pour la filière fruits et légumes et ça
aurait inconcevable de ne pas réagir les
responsabilités avec pragmatisme
vis-à-vis de nos producteurs et en
particulier de nos producteurs de pommes
je vous remercie